[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich sehe die wirtschaft in dem
bundesland seit vorstellung mit der
agrarpolitik
2022 plus skizziert
[Musik]
die vision ist dass man landwirtschaft
machen was eigentlich eine gute
möglichen butter und der pflanze unter
der
haut aber nur wünsche
dass landwirte paar will mit 500
genossenschaftern zusammenarbeiten und
mit ihnen die kosten die arbeit und die
ernte teilen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
geschmacklich will intensiv
in der schweiz schließen jedes jahr rund
1000 betriebe zu groß der aufwand zu
tief die preise für ihre produkte
auf diesem hof soll das wirtschaftliche
risiko auf viele schultern verteilt
werden
ein film über eine idee die
landwirtschaft auch funktionieren könnte
[Musik]
die motoren und dank sehr positiv aus
mit der achtung waren bekannte es mit
seiner großen krise aber ab da hier
wirklich
tina siegenthaler und viele konnten den
hof vor drei jahren pachten
bei der kirschenernte könnten sie jede
helfende hand gut gebrauchen
da sie jetzt hier machen das kommt für
ökologische sie aber das ist dann mit
mehr aufwand verbunden und wenn man da
irgendetwas unterstützen wollt ihr da so
hauffe finanziell tragen und
ertragen denn ist möglich
und jetzt im moment wenn man halt für
den markt produziert manchmal viel
abstriche wo man aber eigentlich machen
wird ein für beruf oder für irgendwas
aber es liegt einfach zeitlich nicht
drin wenn manche sagen aber dann halt
dann einfacher krieg kein geld dafür
also kannst du sag mal die hose
aufräumen wieder wird
der biologische landbau ist
knochenarbeit
jagel kreis der stube kämpfen weil wenn
die überhand nimmt dann hat einfach
weniger futter auf der weit und wie soll
ich sagen irgendwie keine giftigen
mittler insolvenz könnte etwa mit der
sense machen
wir das arbeitszeiterfassung macht und
eben mal zum schauen und das sind wir
also zwischen 250 und 300 stunden im
monat
das sind fast doppelt so viele stunden
wie ein normaler arbeitnehmer leistet
dafür zahlen sie sich momentan je 1700
franken lohn aus
zurzeit sind 35 rinder auf dem hof ihr
fleisch ist eine wichtige einnahmequelle
die die jeder hier dass sie eigentlich
die sogenannte überzahl ließ die
milchwirtschaft wird julia des jahren
muss es hauptgebäude dass die community
zu erwarten und ja dann haben es die
tiere wenn sie über sechs monate und
klasse bis die stürze gewesen ab und
macht eigentlich aus dem gras und ist
ein pfleger mir wünschen eine krasse
machen sie quasi eigentlich gülle und
mist wollen wir brauchen für die
bodenfruchtbarkeit für dünger und und
machen fleisch womit dessen als menschen
die tiere sind jedoch ein
diskussionspunkt
was hauptsächlich natürlich dass nur
wenige tierarten es gehört bis heute zu
hören dass der hof die
beiden teilen sich den hof mit der
gemüse kooperative ort oloko
[Musik]
auf gemeinsamen anbau setzen in der
schweiz bislang rund 70 kooperativen
unter anderem in bern basel und vor
allem in der westschweiz
in dietikon bei zürich produziert otto
loco ausschließlich gemüse und
verteiltes wöchentlich an die 500
mitglieder
[Musik]
als gegenleistung verpflichten sie sich
für ein jahr und bezahlen einen fixen
beitrag im voraus
als genossenschaft darin arbeitet
rothmeier corp mehrere tage im jahr mit
sowie alle mitglieder die knossos
leisten 70 prozent der betrieblichen
arbeiten
dieser schadstoffe wie wir jetzt mehr
freut macht und den großen garten wo
viele manche bewirtschaftet ich bin
unabhängig mache einfach bankhofer
mitzieht hat
und wenn wir in summe irgendwo weg ist
denn nach einem dreher für 1000 sache
geht nicht kaputt
die gemüse kooperative hat drei
angestellte gärtner ihnen
mehr so viele früchte pflanzen und darum
muss man
sich
eigentlich alles an was ich genoss es
gern us sind glaubt 50 kulturtechnik
insgesamt und aber blanik machen wir
immer so an die ort fürs nächste jahr wo
alles drauf geschaut und gedacht
übersichtlich war es wie lange auf dem
beet also jedes bezeichnet meint ritter
portale und wahrscheinlich die flucht
volk die
zehn jahre nach der gründung bildet
oloko das fundament für den nächsten
schritt den ganzen hof mit dem getreide
dem obst und den rindern solidarisch
bewirtschaften
es hat viel konsequenter die schwimmer
der ganze hof solidarisch führt und
nicht einfach nur ein betriebszweig also
business und gemüse ist abhängig vom hof
jagen messung die
spielflächen bug der infrastruktur und
es gibt ein relativ schnelles
unglücklich dass er merkt man jetzt
gerade team das ist super das ist super
arbeitsbedingungen
genossenschaften schaffte sie das ganze
wirklich solidarisch produziert und hof
wo quasi eigentlich wie ein teil auch
möglich dass das auch produziert weiter
dass gemäss ich stehe aber nicht
solidarisch
in zukunft sollen die genossenschafter
ihnen auf dem ganzen hof mit seinen 20
hektar mit mitarbeiten
heute informieren sich die mitglieder
der gemüse kooperative darüber was auf
dem hof produziert wird und welche neuen
lebensmittel dazu kommen könnten
mit einer insgesamt jetzt so um 47
hektar ackerland momente bewirtschafter
der
sogenannte frucht vor das heißt wo wir
den platz wo man nicht jedes jahr
zwischen abo sondern es rotiert bisher
18 winterfutter die potente damit sie
nicht vom fleisch kann also wirklich so
sprichwörtlich denn bis wo ganz
klassisch ist dinkel da braucht im
gegensatz zum weiter extrem wenig stoff
und ganz ganz wichtiger teil vor der
flucht vom
spitze und das ist extrem wichtig für
die bio landwirtschaft
wird es gibt eine pause
ich dass irgendeine option für die
zukunft linzer hantieren vielmehr weiter
als zwei ist zum beispiel dann vom bus
caravelle reform hat und was mit den
tieren wird das tier wieder hoch
[Musik]
wieso machte damit
us
[Musik]
firma segway war marisa war herthas das
rund und wir dass es nicht gemacht wurde
er und ich weil ich wirklich gern
mitarbeiter die gerne mit der erde
arbeiten und weil ich auch von daher
kommt von der kindheit her
sich generationenübergreifend es geht
für junge leute es geht doch aspire
academy und das ist ein wunderschöner
gedanken
mega wichtig finde dass die gesellschaft
sich mit themen wie umwelt ernährung und
so weit auseinander es gibt die theorie
dazu selbstverständlich
das papier
bietet sky und so und
was ist red bull ich weiß du etwas glück
danke hat sich so weit wie
wundervoll gala
okay und jack szostak april unterzieht
und so schön und ich habe das privileg
wird jesus ist kein leichtes rennen
italien
texten thaler ist buchhalter und einer
der mitgründer der gemüse kooperative
jeder sind auch der betrieb wurde wenn
du in lahde dort herrschten zwischen
handeln will
um die jährlichen betriebskosten des
gesamten hofes zu decken sind
voraussichtlich
740.000 franken an einnahmen durch die
abos nötig ein voller wo mit allen
produkten würde 2008 150 franken im jahr
kosten oder 240 franken im monat
[Musik]
noch ist nicht sicher ob diese rechnung
wirklich aufgeht vieles ist unklar
der aufbau einer solidarischen
landwirtschaft braucht zeit
20 besonders engagierte gnosis leisten
die denk und organisationsarbeit die
meisten ehrenamtlich gemeinsam wollen
sie den hof nicht nur bewirtschaften
sondern kaufen die idee otto logo gibt
der gmbh von tina ein darlehen nötig ist
ein betrag jenseits der million
gesagt dass mit dem hof dass babys
möglichst noch richtig richtig der
schützenhof
[Gelächter]
also wenn man ganz ehrlich sind haben
die einzigen aber mit unverbindliche
zusage noch nicht
[Gelächter]
aber wir eine große teilten mit die
unverbindliche zusage zugleich sehr
verbindliche zusage und dennoch wird es
dem nutzer stehen oder bauernverband
holen aber das ist den auch nicht was
entscheidend wenn man sagt mir wand aus
der hof leiste wurde und für das team
ihres handelns und punktete dass ich mal
einfach zu der das wo man warnt und
ob das klappt steht noch in den sternen
noch gehört der hof ihm samuel sparen 35
jahre hat er darauf gewirtschaftet nun
wieder verkaufen
wenn wichtige teile ist einfach
kontrolle das quasi das ist aber meine
hand noch island daytona oben am
rangierbahnhof
auch hat da einen hocker gehört dann
noch nicht was dazu tritt der käufe von
der genossenschaft ja
wieso muss
ideellen gründen
ja ich erzeugen wir
an niederschlag bleibt aber es galt ist
mit trotzdem nicht der wichtigste
antrieb sie zum irgendwas mache
sein ganzes leben hat sich der bio
pionier der landwirtschaft verschrieben
von den jetzigen pächtern wollte er sich
zuerst ein bild machen
kann das auf verlangt dass die
handtasche von mir ich will keine
hauptschüler doofen betrieb irgendwo bis
machen ich will das tier biss verstört
vor dass auch dass sie schaue ich habe
mich ich habe mich
einmal meisterprüfung gemacht und
haben mich auch ständig weiterbildet und
ohne das ganz einfach schlichte
unterschied der landwirtschaft nicht
anders stellen
text kurzen thaler will keine zeit
verlieren bald erfährt er ob die
genossenschafter und genossenschafter
rinnen bereit sind den kauf des hofes
mittels anteilsscheinen zu finanzieren
in seinem atelier am stadtrand von
zürich werden jeden moment die resultate
der virtuellen gv aufgeschaltet
so 17 350 ausgaben als sieben minuten
habe ich schon mal locker ist gespannt
neugierig
stehen machen
das ist
[Musik]
okay es
ist so na klar es ist gar keine frage
das ist
ja jetzt
die drei trägt die darlehen soundtrack
sind agno wurden mit
112 114 109 400 ps und
115 also einfach es ist wichtig
der hof kaufen
jakobus
dann machen wir
ein projekt scheint auf kurs doch text
tschurtschenthaler möchte mehr er will
mithelfen die idee auch in die berge zu
bringen
[Musik]
die selva kanton graubünden hier soll
die erste solidarische landwirtschaft
kurz solari in den bergen entstehen eine
perspektive für die unter druck
stehenden bergbauern und
[Musik]
meistens ein ja ist bis zweimal im jahr
bis zum letzten moment bin ich
hier ja und das war nicht möglich
wenn ihr jetzt auch chemikalien
grossverteiler weil er will poulter und
ist unser land fahren
[Musik]
wir haben geben wenn ich weiß wo eine
mini produkten und einer cola
der welt mit über hunger
[Musik]
das ist für mich auch
eine ganz am anfang stand juni
an interessierte für die
solarwerte kontakt zu der hundehalter
ein bisserl intensivieren und robin
kraft sowie das ist der
erste gedanke
jonas ley kommt ursprünglich aus zürich
und pachtet den betrieb seit vier jahren
wieder zum teil auch
das kommt mir sehr darüber
und bruder
eli
sehr gerne umgang mit dem tier ja und
damit die pflanze
16 auf der wiese und im wald
oder
direktzahlungen
und von den produkten der
umsatz stellt vielleicht irgendwo wie
diese jungen alles zusammen genau
und ja aber was dann schluss blieb dem
sozialen
abstieg
diesen jahres gewinn erwirtschaftet er
alleine erhalten vom betrieb ist das
größte projekt momentums
[Musik]
teil des solar wie projektes ist doch
selbst ines ins um mit der bergbau hat
verschiedene standbeine
nebenbei mache mir hocke mora der
hauptziel mindestens sicher so dass
biodiversität
studios
machen die idee wäre auch sie könnte das
hauptberuflich machen aber
körperlich gesundheitlich jeden tag so
conny wenn zwei tage macht es dem
musiker bis machen wo
doch das
konzept eines kann sich vorstellen
seinen betriebszweig obst in die
solidarische landwirtschaft zu geben
ist es langsamen
spitzweg der spitze fiel mir sind
daneben auch immer der jüngste oder und
wenig sehen wie viel muss das könnte
ihnen parierte und mehr gleichzeitig
dass mit dem markt co aufgehängt denn
herne mühe zum das am mann frau bringen
und wer die idee des mitte solidarische
landwirtschaft sie können mir gott helfe
aber können
der obst so 10 grad haben so weise ganz
sicher dass das ass verwertet wird will
das kabinett hat es einfach am boden
nicht
und das ja auch nicht ruf legt oder
nullsummenspiel
und vor der soli wird das entgolten des
mini arbeit entschädigt wird
so was lässt
also finanziell vor der direktzahlungen
ist absolut und nachher
vom landwirtschaftlicher betrieb
haltung gesagt seit 50 heimann und das
ist es so
selbst weiß noch nicht wann er aufhört
und auch nicht was dann mit seinem hof
passiert
momentan geht es glaube nicht in der
schweiz den sein
hoymer dem landwirt ist sondern eine
solidarische
landwirtschaft verein momentan der wurm
ihr gründet hand oder später
genossenschaft
[Musik]
vor einem halben jahr ist samuel sparen
zusammen mit seiner frau in eine
stadtwohnung gezogen zurück auf seinen
hof kommt er vor allem zu musizieren
[Musik]
das hat für mich so viel ab werk
qualität oder was zu ihnen ist kurz
kommt überall wo die hannelore gesehen
ich bin ja auch witzig gemacht haben ist
das htc evo nicht zu dem besuch lierhaus
leben haben oder also ich bin auch sie
haben die möglichkeit
aber verdammt das hat mich uhren auf
strand und ich haben unglaublich
geschaffen die der ec
gibt es rund sieben stunden woche und
ich habe sie ja ich habe wirklich sehr
viel herz glauben aber das hätte man
wahrscheinlich nichts schlimmste sie
sich dass man das mich ganz ganz viele
andere ist auch einer planung
interessiert hätte und dass sie schon
drei wochen abstimmen auch die intensive
betrieb bio führt und mit sehr
positive betriebsstruktur also oft auch
hier direkt auf
ja es ist die eine klage machte diesen
verlieren glaubt durch den hof aber es
hat nicht lange zu mir gemächlich
sporthilfe und und ich
uns vorrang avk
pensionskosten und mir an der besucher
zu relativ
sporten.dk automatisch wieder öffnen ob
er das lange ende und alle mini ersparen
ist ausgearbeitet haben lima besteck
tage nach dem hof und so soll ich nicht
und darum uns kaufen wenn ich jetzt
nehme ich aktiv bin so ist das
zu hause bei genossenschaften ruth meyer
kommt die gemüsefelder von denen sie und
ihr mann sich mehrheitlich ernähren
liegen in sichtweite
für den hof kauf überweisen die beiden
ein zinsloses darlehen von 20000 franken
pro maschine und zurecht ohne mit bohnen
salat mit mangold
und ein
dass da ich vor dem moment der tasche
hat und das lange der woche wir sind
froh dass mit autoteilen mit anderen
zusammen kochen sie was die ernte ein
paar tage zuvor hergibt
zudem haben wir jetzt zur kraft hertha
wird so ohne zurufe und
den vorwurf zurück dass mit der härte
politisches man bereits
jetzt also was brauchen wir eigentlich
holen
solari hat ja vor dass nachweise und
basta
von pc und im moment tut es noch nicht
möglich ist ja da haben es
das leben ganz schön zum zug
ich habe ab und zu sieht man wirklich
von otto logos andersohn intensiver
geschmack mit also vor allem cross
später tomaten also ich kann ihre
automaten das ist das gewaltig
ich musste ihnen ist und manchmal dass
gerade nachrichten und mainz gibt es für
mich persönlich habe ich inzwischen
verblichenen
sollten also dass da bin ich zwei
dreimal hintereinander gleich
[Musik]
gerade jetzt wollen wir die schwierige
zeit und mit dem virus
nachfrage jahr nachdem das man lieber
mehr regionale sache
produktmix mit aha moment wisse nicht ob
das land
ein großer punkt wenn du das wirklich
systems habe ich
versuchen etwas mit respekt sich
komplett selbst versorgen die heutige
zeit aber doch mit als die zurück zu
müssen jetzt 2 500 strukturen
von einer häufung der genossenschaften
[Musik]
auch in der selva geht es vorwärts an
diesem wochenende finden schnuppertage
für die solidarische landwirtschaft in
den bergen statt
20 personen aus dem unterland packen auf
verschiedenen betrieben mit an
fußball denken aber können und zwar der
strauß der gut
400 meter der spitzkehre und bei der
spitzkehre hensley straßenbauprogramm
disco und dezimieren machen und die
fans kümmern
und dann ganz weg ganz sicher
[Musik]
aggressivität die thoma
will so könnte man nicht einfach so
heraus passieren
generell warnt region so ina
wäre die mine trauer auch ich selber
der steuerfrage ich wohne ich selber zum
höhe trieben auf welche inhalte auftrieb
aber das wird wahrscheinlich eine andere
frage ist ja
[Musik]
dass man bewusst wenn ich tanze produkt
kann zu mir
wir müssen
die grossverteiler damit nährstoffe
besser
als ob sie uns
ich suche ja also mit fahrzeugen sowie
so
[Musik]
ich habe für rosen dann geht es an und
so eine haarnadel kurve rutschte aus
grußkarten ich musste gerade straßen
absperren und hoffe dass für die kurven
aber mit einem souveränen
gott du dorthin lotste sie betonen in
ihren
und du warst der tara und letzter
sekunde
[Musik]
ja
ich glaube ich glaube da jetzt die drei
kurven aber das haben wir eine kleine
höchste vorher
[Musik]
wer
[Applaus]
sich jetzt
verschenken hat
ich als ausdruck dass das etui 2 hertha
hat oder nicht nur eine
villa mir manche funktioniert das wie
heute ich merke einfach ein paar sachen
wo man sich für dann wenn die welt so la
vie so richtig los geht
[Musik]
das nicht dass nicht auch ich mir also
mühsamer wird für pur mit ios also
in dietikon stimmt die genossenschaft
darüber ab wie der hof in zukunft
bewirtschaftet werden soll
in zeiten der pandemie versammeln sich
die mitglieder in der neuen reithalle
ich hoffe und gehe davon aus dass die
ausserordentliche generalversammlung
den vorliegenden ideen zustimmt und
freue mich wenn der hof so erhalten
bleiben als kleiner ort mit großen
hoffnungen aus bio
als beispiel dafür dass landwirtschaft
auch ohne ausbeutung und von mensch und
umwelt es funktionieren kann
was passiert jetzt wenn wir einen
totalschaden haben das ist wie wenn man
halt eine firma hat ein unternehmen hat
man eine unternehmen risiko in dem heft
steht drin dass die anzahl der in den
essgewohnheiten der mitglieder angepasst
wird und da würde ich noch ein bisschen
mehr gerne mehr etwas darüber hören das
neue hof konzept das budget und die
geplanten investitionen werden mit
großer mehrheit angenommen
[Musik]
zwei jahre planung diskussionen und
denkarbeit zahlen sich aus
für den hof kauf zeichnet jeder haushalt
durchschnittlich sechseinhalb 1000
franken anteilscheine manche deutlich
mehr ich habe und auf dem grund um dem
lärm echt mega will dass mich so
so wichtig ist ich kann so springen über
moment jemand zum fahrer morgens später
fahrer kann ich oft dafür bin ich dem
kapital kann ich nicht viel kann ich
viel kapital bieten wo dennoch aufrecht
sitzt wegen geldfluss ist
in andere ja sowie partner der hand sagt
mit und jetzt mal 15.000 franken
investiere ideal sie dass ein teilweiser
mal für sein altes reserve aber mir hat
das gemacht im bewusstsein dass viele
weniger anteile werden können zeichnen
und wenn wir es gründer machen muss
ab nächstem jahr erhalten die beiden
landwirte statt 1700 je
4100 franken lohn
[Musik]
heute geben tina siegenthaler und
ventile ein rind an einem grossverteiler
voraussichtlich zum letzten mal
schönes leben gehabt hat für die zeit
und ja ist ja auch fleisch und von dem
er sie kann da schon gute hinter stehen
aber sich natürlich für jedes mal ein
abschied ist klar weil die gleichen
kriegs und wenn sie hat dann so reetz
entgehen so
ab nächstem jahr sollen vor allem die
mitglieder der solidarischen
landwirtschaft das fleisch der tiere
konsumieren
ein bio rind darf nicht älter als 27
monate sein und sein schlachtgewicht
nicht mehr als 280 kilogramm betragen
das schreibt der grossverteiler vor
es geht halt das sei mal um das
gesamtgewicht mit einem schlachtgewicht
kilowatt genauer und gefahren das heißt
du musst dir wie du früher abgeben wenn
sie eigentlich doch knopf aufmachen
würden nur sagt schlachter wenn sie wird
ja genauso und argument ist dass der
konsument nicht ein zu großes antritt
gott dann zum beispiel abgepackt hat
weil das wäre ja zu teuer obwohl ja der
kilopreis genau gleich ist
[Musik]
auf eis liegt
wie sich die fleisch
tv digital
5.1 auf das hat genauso wie mündung
katze aber
natürlich wenn man sie
schlachtet
das
möchte das
richtig
[Musik]
wenn man jetzt gesehen dass mit viel
fleisch produziert dann ist das thema
werte also der nicht nur von mir und die
aber machen also wenn es nur für die das
empfehlen dass man jetzt hat wenig
verändert hat ja
es ist wirklich personen braucht
eigentlich die bühne wir brauchen da
mischt damit die wilde flucht bleiben
und das ist ganz neues konzept wenn du
nachher mit
methode mit gründen
mit hoffenheim vor weniger ertrag oder
so denn durch landwirtschaft betrieb und
die danken fahrleistungen militärische
befreiung der maulburger was passiert
müssen sie einfach noch nicht so liegt
das material aber fahre also dass der
ungefähr 80 zum ackerbau machen ob er
operiert
und dann macht zu kommen sind
makler ab was die politik
tut jemand jüngeres und
fleisch
so
2020 die hier auf die fläche von
20 hektar insgesamt ruft eigentlich
schon das hätte jetzt das
aber das wird richtig findet sie wie ihr
viel dass es vertrete hier dass man
heuer aber fahre mir dass mein bruder
fluggerät hat denn wirklich noch
aufrecht halten
bei jonas lane falls sind über das
wochenende zwei familien angereist
noch vor seinen gästen muss er sich um
seine schafe kümmern einige könnten
jeden moment lang
wo man singt da sind auch geplant aber
sie meistens um die 25 grad
und da sind auch in der winterzeit
gestellt
hatten die yahoo
da sind irgendwann bin ich dann
organisieren und koordinieren und das
lernen
hier
[Applaus]
yahoo nicht gereinigt
das ist nach geburt
von drei euro gesammelt hat die frist
jetzt
und die lasse sie eine klasse damit die
stets mit der wolf
ist deshalb
gut möglich dass du nach geburt oder das
auto geraten
ist kommt
und nehme islam und probierst in dem
raum gewünscht
[Musik]
da wir hier
hier werde zur zwischen
neun monaten und jährige also sicher
sein dass der nächste auktion
weiterzumachen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im sturmzentrum
vorstellt dass
mitarbeiter
ist was ich nur für die familie ich sage
erkennt dass meine zeit als
organisationen
zum vergnügen sagen kann dass man seit
das muss eben auch die
stellt er arbeite wo sich könnte metro
oder sind älter einfach froh und mache
die arbeit was braucht und
für kinder macht billig nur der
stahlwerker passt eigentlich nicht
wirklich selber sind
dann einfach weiter beschäftigen sie
verschaffen oder rechts von der
mitarbeit würde das bringen
definitiv naja
das ist unglaublich also dem ersten tag
[Musik]
wer bei der solidarischen
berglandwirtschaft mitmacht verpflichtet
sich für drei jahre
pro jahr sind drei tage mitarbeit
geplant dafür gibt es fleisch käse und
apfelmost eine mitgliedschaft kostet
1100 franken im jahr
mit dem potenzial als für andere also
mit produzenten
in dialog was für sie gut bis man sie
sich wünscht was für
ein minimum an vertriebskanal
großbetrieb wie katja das wird ihnen
leisten
wir uns gerne machen was ich gerne habe
wo sie muss also für ihre stadt zu stadt
einiges mehr als nur zahlen und
rief danke
dass ihr auf anderen ebenen
einige sieht ihre glaub ich bin
zuversichtlich dass das klappt das ist
mindestens einmal aus experiment haben
vom start
weg ist natürlich schwierig mit einer
wechsel aber das will ich konsumiere
produktiv sowieso und dann jetzt diese
dann bei komplizierten das natürlich
optimal
so vorstellen dass dafür das mitglied
ist
das ist der erste berg so leer wie
vertraut wo da jetzt unterschrieben
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für das werk solle wie funktioniert mit
vorgesehene fünf betrieb brauchen 400
haushalt mit rundgang die musik
mitglieder
also
gestern und 70 mir bezahlt oder 12 2 mio
und wenn man sich in gruppen oder 2
[Musik]
ich glaube dass kurz nach
das erste produkt süßmost wird für die
verteilung unter den genossenschafter
ihnen verladen ein erster kleiner
schritt ist gemacht
[Musik]
dann glauben es wird nichts ok glaubt es
nicht aber
i lon mit den gern überraschen will ich
genau wie es in der mafa stadium aber
die die motivation vorderleute und was
die alles auf baustellen so also das
überrascht mich immer wieder wie
ein jahr später umfasst die
genossenschaft solidarische
landwirtschaft in den bergen 40
mitglieder
mittlerweile hat ein zweiter für das
projekt unterschrieben und bald startet
die eigene käseproduktion
dietikon sechs monate nach gründung der
solidarischen landwirtschaft ist klar im
ersten jahr wird die genossenschaft
einen verlust von 50000 franken
schreiben welches unternehmer oder weil
es geschafft hätte im ersten jahr
schwarze zahlen
[Musik]
einige genossenschafter und
genossenschafter rinnen sind im ersten
jahr beim gemüse aber geblieben und
haben noch nicht davon voll abo
gewechselt
mittlerweile können die mitglieder auf
dem hof getreide das fleisch der rinder
öl und tofu beziehen alles eigene
produkte
das gemüse wird weiterhin in eines der
17 depots in der stadt zürich gefahren
jede woche übernimmt jemand anderes den
ablack oder den fahrdienst
[Musik]
in den depots holen die genossenschafter
und genossenschafter rinnen ihr essen ab
[Musik]
also egal wie schwierig das ist mein
gesicht und wissen nicht dass es gibt es
entstellt
[Musik]
es ist nicht destruktiv sondern es ist
möglich aber konstruktiv und es ist ja
schon mal fahren
news limited rsipl
hochschule und lebensmittel produzieren
und versteht es für mich im zentrum
ausland bieten produzentin aber das ist
alles sehr schaftliche projekt wo man
halt wirklich mögen wir haben zunächst
system transformieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]